well I I mean and not because it's you
sitting here but the calendar is really
the aggregation point for most of that
right because I mean not that for square
hasn't interfaced to that yet but
they'll figure it out um or whether it's
moved to some other location service uh
you know goala or Facebook says they're
going to do one now or whatever it's
going to be but um it's still event
driven in some way shape or form so I
won't say meeting driven that would be
you know sort of internal thought but
event driven that okay today there's a
launch of ludus live so what's going to
happen I've got a internal conference
call on it I've got a external
conference call on it I want to be
monitoring what the analysts and press
are saying about it how is all that
going to come together and make a
productive day for me I know by the way
factor into that that my daughter's bust
will arrive home at 4:15 and she needs
to be at the you know friend's house by
5: and the baby needs to go down at 7
right so you know time still is at its
Essence the thing that drives human
behavior absolutely sun goes down Sun
comes off right so it seems like the
calendar is probably the most logical
place to bring together all the things
going on in the world and again not just
saying that for the camera but but you
know but that's that is a vision that I
think everybody's kind of driving
towards every one of those other apps
that you mentioned has a Time driven
element to it for square wants to know
you know two hours ago here's who where
your other friends checked in or 10
minutes ago somebody else you don't know
checked in in the same place you're in
right so it's addressing time in two
Dimensions uh tripid is completely date
driven right Twitter your Twitter stream
you almost never go back more than an
hour or two when you sit down and go
look at Twitter because anything older
than that doesn't really matter right
you know it's Twitter doesn't have a
metaphor some of the apps do but Twitter
and of itself doesn't think of a
metaphor that says here's the latest
update from everybody you follow it's
completely timeline driven so time is
really driving everything absolutely